like the flu for some people if you're  older if you're already sick if your  immune system is compromised again this  is just for me reading a couple articles  i'm not an expert because it's easily  communicable it will be a pandemic  but  whether or not we just like the flu  there's a vaccine but there's no cure  once you get it right  it'll become seasonal in other words  we're going to see this on a rotating  basis that's another flu strain yes with  a virus somehow we're going to have  maybe we'll have medicine for it at some  point a vaccine i'm sure at some point  we'll figure it out it takes about a  year yeah or who knows how long but just  like there's a flu season and we know to  get vaccine for the flu season there'll  be a corona season and i'm not talking  about with jimmy buffett and having a  beer right so it will happen  and your best  you know reaction is to stay healthy and  help you know  be well right and help your employees  and your family do the same thing